president honorable members
last Friday it was International
anti-corruption Day
on this day of all days
Belgian authorities carried out searches
on several addresses in Brussels
as of last evening 20 searches have been
carried out
on suspicion of involvement in organized
crime corruption and money laundering
they filed charges against four people
including one former member of this
Parliament and the vice president of the
European Parliament
the investigations cover a wider Network
They confiscated computers
smartphones and over half a million
euros in cash
we do not yet know what the results of
this investigation will be but one thing
is clear there must be zero tolerance
for corruption
thank you
corruption is a very serious crime that
undermines our democracy our economy our
society the I applaud the Belgian police
and the Belgian authorities for the
decisive action in this criminal
investigation and for showing that
prosecution and the law enforcement
system work
and I applaud the officials and members
of this house who are fully assisting
this investigation and I thank president
mezula for your personal support of the
investigation your decisive action your
resolve to meet these tests and have the
parliament come to out stronger
the allegations are extremely serious
the investigations are still ongoing and
there is a presumption of innocence
but to anyone
accepting payoffs kickbacks
bribes
I say
shame on you
[Applause]
shame on you for violating trust the
trust of the people of Europe who expect
you to fight for their interest not your
own and for violating the trust of your
colleagues here in the parliament who
work very hard honorably truthfully with
decency
the only way we can rebuild trust is to
fully support investigations
for the guilty to be brought to Justice
and for us to root out corruption
anywhere we find it
as president from The Lion said in her
State of the Union speech three months
ago in this chamber corruption erodes
trust we must fight back with the full
force of the law
and that's what we must do every day
our anti-fraud office Olaf investigates
fraud and corruption in the institutions
the European public prosecutor's office
fight crimes against the EU budget we
have a strong rule of law mechanism to
help all member states fight corruption
with annual monitoring and Reporting and
now also clear recommendations
we set up a general law conditionality
mechanism to make sure no money from the
EU budget goes into corrupt Pockets we
took steps to make sure no scent of
coveted recovery money ends up in the
wrong hands the fight against corruption
is Central to our strategy against
organized crime
and a key Target of European police
cooperation under impact
a union we need to learn the hard
lessons
and take responsibility
ensuring that we have better mechanism
and accountability in place
get rid of differences in National laws
that obstruct the fight against
corruption
that's why I next year will propose a
new law
we must criminalize all forms of
corruption in all member states
not just bribery as is the case today
but also trafficking and influence
illicit enrichment embezzlement and
abuse of power
and to impose tough eu-wide criminal
penalties for these crimes
the commission continues to support an
EU ethics body for All European
institutions for the parliament Council
for the European court of justice the
ECB the European Court of auditors
and also it's advisory buddies European
economic and social committee and the
committee of The Obedience without
exception
so we can all live by the same Clear
principles live up to the same high
standards
president from The Lion sent a letter to
these institutions in March and vice
president Yoruba is carrying the
discussions with our partners forward
let me be clear the Scandal we discussed
here today goes well beyond ethics
violations
it's a criminal
a serious criminal investigation
the parliament's first response is the
right one to cooperate fully with the
law enforcement
but there is anger and frustration in
this house and outside
there is understandable outrage and
frustration among the millions who
believe in the European project
who saw the European Unity helped us
through the pandemic and helps us now in
response to Putin's War
we build trust based on action and now
we must rebuild
the fight against corruption is Mission
critical for Europe
and we must have our own house in order
first
our standards should always be the
highest
it's what we expect of others and we
must demand it for ourselves
thank you
you're taking tank
thank you very much commissioner thank
you for the clarity of your intervention
and your statement
thank you once again for the clarity
and the assessment that you've made of
the situation
and uh with only one vote against
uh hmm
Madame Kylie is now removed as vice
president of this house
and Mr yaron Leonards now colleagues
it's really hard to express how sad and
angry I am here today because the greed
of some individuals in this house has
caused a dark shadow over all of us and
I have to fully agree with the
commissioner's shame on them the news
over the past days looked like a bad
Netflix film bags of cash rated offices
and searched houses but it's not a film
it's the ugly truth of high-level
corruption at the heart of the European
democracy and of course investigations
are ongoing and we need to wait for all
the facts but already I would want to
thank the Belgian authorities and I
would also like to thank our president
Roberta metzola for her leadership on
this issue and Echo her words there will
be no impunity none those responsible
must be brought to Justice and we fully
support the internal investigation that
the president announced we must do
better increased transparency and
accountability of all activities
related to third countries whether
through ngos or other actors and
strengthen defensive tools and
anti-corruption measures to combat
foreign interference in our work all
these steps are necessary to start
regaining the trust of our citizens
because make no mistakes the action of
those who rather take home bags of cash
than bags of work they undermine The
credibility of all of us and it is up to
us together to repair the damage and we
can already see the orbons of this world
gloating about these developments
apparently under the impression that
corruption elsewhere makes corruption at
home less disgusting nonsense and let me
emphasize one crucial difference in
stark contrast to the impunity in urban
Hungary in a rule of law corrupt
individuals are arrested prosecuted and
stripped of their responsibilities and
we say very clearly here today no
tolerance for corruption no tolerance
for impunity thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
and now
the president of the snd group
thank you president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
this Parliament has always worked and
will continue to work for democracy rule
of law and transparency we've always
fought against corruption in all its
forms and we will continue doing so but
we recognize that we have to do better
corruption destroys institutions
undermines the confidence of citizens
and damages a political image we cannot
allow this because we're here to serve
our citizens
notwithstanding our ideological
differences I'm very proud of the
reaction of this house when faced with
this horrible Scandal of corruption that
unfortunately has taken place in the
parliament having said that there are
some key points to make first of all
those responsible are the people that
broke the law and that committed serious
crimes that they were aware of and the
full force of the law needs to fall on
them and then I've already announced
that my group will also be involved in
any court case
now we have to say that in fact the fact
that there is a criminal investigation
underway proves that rule of law does
work and we will do everything we can to
cooperate with the investigation so that
all facts are known my responsibility as
group leader
is to ensure that any negative impact
that could happen from what is what
these people have done will be
counteracted both in the group and
elsewhere we will be work we will be
acting firmly we will be carrying out an
internal investigation we acted firmly
from the outset to protect the
honorability of the Social Democrat
group as well as this Parliament because
criminal behavior of a few individuals
cannot undermine the everyday work done
by the immense majority of MEPS
and their staff and assistance and we
have to set up I think a committee of
inquiry in the European Parliament
because apart from this criminal
Behavior we have to know what internal
mechanisms can be improved to ensure
that we do not see a situation like this
again we want maximum Clarity and
transparency taking into account that
the legal investigation has not
concluded the most important is that
that continues and that all the facts
are known over the next weeks we are
going to have to discuss concrete
measures such as the time frame and
mandate for the committee of inquiry the
need to include third countries on the
transparency register for lobbies or the
creation of an independent Essex Body it
must be clear to Citizens this house is
transparent it belongs to you all and
this awful episode will never happen
again
this house needs to be an open house to
all of those who want to contribute to
building a United Europe a fairer Europe
because it our work is worth it because
it is worth working for Europe even on
days as sad as this one and it is worth
working for a Europe where we are all
working together thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much our next speaker is
from the regional group
yes thank you chair
colleagues
shock disbelief
anger
I believe we all went through the roller
coaster last weekend as bit by bit we
learned about the corruption Scandal
that took place in our midst and we are
still reeling or at least that's the way
I feel we're all devastated to see how
the criminal acts of members former
members and staff of the European
Parliament have deeply damaged the image
of this house
and it is our task to restore and even
strengthen trust we have a saying in
Dutch trust arrives on foot and leaves
on Horseback in other words it takes a
long time to build trust but it's broken
very rapidly
taking influence on political decision
making is in itself a normal and healthy
part of democracy let's not forget that
as a matter of fact it is democracy and
MEPS must be accessible and open to
arguments and debate they must be able
to freely and independently be the voice
of their constituents and vote in line
with their own views and beliefs
but it's a very different matter if
actors are trying to get influence with
undue pressures or even bribes and the
Ugly facts that have emerged are not a
mere breach of Ethics colleagues but
criminal Acts
and we can fortunately conclude that the
criminal justice system works now let's
use this momentum and revise and
strengthen the rules on ethics and
transparency nevertheless there is
already a number of proposals on the
table like finally setting up an Ethics
body with teeth and expanding the
transparency register to include Third
Country representatives and much more
and we can learn from the best practices
from other parliaments this house
colleagues must and can become the gold
standard for integrity and transparency
and it is our joint cross party task to
restore trust thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much colic uh next
speaker
is from the greens and
thank you I think we're all still
horrified by what
emerged in the weekend
and my father had some fairly strong
words about it
I think it shows that trust has been
broken and we can only reconstruct a
trust if we act in the European
Parliament we've got to be very clear in
the resolution that we adopt that we
have to
speak out against what's happened and
the consequences are obviously clear
reaction to corruption is Central we've
taken the first steps today
in having strips of her officers vice
president corruption must have
consequences full stop no discussion
we need full investigation and of course
we need full cooperation with the
Belgian authorities
because
they've shown that there is a free and
independent Judiciary in Belgium and
something is very important is that we
take measures to prevent this in the
future
and the things that you can't prevent
even with better rules transparency but
nevertheless we must focus on full
transparency for example
including countries in the lobby
register and some colleagues are going
to say that we shouldn't rush our fences
we shouldn't react immediately but there
are a lot of rules which
we've already adopted by by the future
but by majority here in the plenary
as the rules of ethics and we should
continue to implement this because this
is not a new discussion it's just come
to the fore again and I think that
through this discussion we've got to
keep in our minds that we need to
reconstruct the faith in the parliament
with the citizens that's got to be the
main point thank you
president
thank you very much the religion of
Human Rights and so where the religion
of money starts
we've always tried to moralize and we've
already we've always
tried to lecture to other countries and
now we're in the middle of a scandal
involving in Islam's country these this
brings to the end the Masquerade which
claims that Europe is a great thing the
ones who shout loudest about democracy
we have people here in a parliament who
are suspected of getting money from
Qatar Qatar is an islamist
a country that has no rights of women's
there's no right of workers
homosexuality
is
okay
sentenced to the death penalty this is a
country where thousands of people died
building the arenas for the World Cup
and the Players Sports women have to
wear Veil they sponsor the Terrace in
Syria and in France according to France
Bruno
the Muslim Brotherhood
has been
funded to the extent 25
000 Euros over the last years in
setting up schools and so forth how many
of the MEPS are prepared to sell out to
the highest bidder
who how many have the same views we
don't want to ask countries to be sold
to the highest bidder we have to
shed light on the links of MEPS with
Qatar and I'm sure there are other
skeletons and cupboards this is just the
beginning on the subject of Qatar and a
lot of subjects we have
said for a long time we have to impose
respect for Europe for everybody thank
you nice
um thank you very much now I call it
Casita canker has the floor
foreign
president
ladies and gentlemen
corruption money laundering so much cash
that it took the whole night to count it
all up we're not talking about drugs
gangs or the mafia we're talking about
members of this Parliament and their
staff
I'm angry just like everybody else I'm
disappointed that there's so much egoism
here
lack of respect for democracy and our
citizens
why don't they go to Qatar why don't
they move there if they want to
represent Qatar because they know we
have rules of under the rule of law here
the rule of law are things that we need
to cherish not undermine them
Qatar has undermined the confidence in
our institutions and the rule of law
this situation these circumstances these
Revelations
are
demanding at the same time that we in
this house look into what's happened we
investigate this and how we can make
sure we avoid this in the future
our institutions have to act quickly and
effectively to make sure that we regain
confidence here rules of integrity and
ethics have to be tightened up Lobby
rules need to be revised when it comes
to Third Country actors we have to have
effective implementation of the rules
this is not Club Med in Europe in
Parliament to get rid of the
Parliamentary delegations we know that
they're worthless and the Committees can
actually cover that work
this investigation has to carry out be
carried out properly so that everybody
knows that the people who are trying to
buy others or the people who are corrupt
will never remain without impunity that
is what decent working members of the
community and of this Parliament expect
thank you very much and now for the left
left in Sheridan
thank you very much Mr President many
people are currently
facing problems
people are struggling to bring their
shopping home and yet here we've got
members of this house with suitcases
full of cash trundling through the town
it's very difficult to know the scale of
the current situation but what we need
is total cooperation with the
authorities to uncover the facts and to
make sure that the transparency rules of
this house are respective
this my group calls for a committee to
get to the bottom
of uh what has happened
we need total
openness and transparency is it normal
for States and companies to buy
influence on European policy this is a
major Blow To The credibility of
European politics quite clearly
political Decisions by this house have
been paid for and there are members of
this house who let themselves be bought
we're not talking here about a few bad
apples this Scandal has happened because
we have a structural problem how many
lobbyists had access
to the European Parliament over the past
year how many meetings were there
between lobbyists and Commissioners and
commission officials how much do we
really know about the influence of
lobbyists and States on our institution
and others we need an independent ethics
commission and total transparency in
legislative work otherwise this Scandal
is going to tarnish the EU for a long
time to come thank you
thank you very much next Laura Ferrara
you have the flow
thank you very much
the Scandal stemming from the serious
suspicions of corruption from Qatar has
tarnished the image of the European
parliaments casting a shadow on it and
it is uh jeopardizing people's trust in
our institution we have to cooperate
with Justice in order to defend the
credibility and the honor of the
parliament which is the house of all
Europeans and European democracy we have
to make sure we get to the bottom of
this and make sure what we find out what
the truth is and that everyone is held
accountable I'd like to thank president
mitsula so for everything she's done we
have to make sure that we don't give in
to any Act of interference attack
corruption and so on that undermines
decision making and democracy the
five-star movement
shares the fact that we should postpone
the vote on a waving visa rules for
Qatar and Kuwait we have to make sure
that it becomes mandatory to have a
register which reflect MEPS meeting
lobbyists and foreign diplomats we
cannot tolerate those who jeopardize The
credibility of the representatives and
European democracy thank you
thank you very much and next we'll hear
from David McAllister
Mr President ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues trust in our parliament's
integrity and the rule of law
are Paramount for the functioning of
European democracy the European
Parliament must conduct a policy of zero
tolerance towards corruption
for this reason I am appalled about four
people closely connected to the European
Parliament including one of its vice
presidents were arrested by the Belgian
authorities on suspicions of money
laundering corruption and participating
in a criminal organization
I've very much welcome president Roberta
mitsula's leadership her words yesterday
here in this hemicircle I welcome her
initiative to launch an internal
investigation and the whites ranging
reform process in order to increase
transparency and to fight corruption it
is important that we now draw the right
conclusions
colleagues for European Parliament
cannot assume the role of a court and
does not intend to Prejudice ongoing
investigations yet I congratulate the
relevant Belgian and further European
authorities on thwarting further
criminal actions through their work
Parliament should fully support the
ongoing criminal investigation for any
foreign actor proven guilty in this
ongoing case there must also be Swift
and persuasive consequences
the European Parliament needs to
strengthen our anti-corruption
mechanisms as well as defensive tools to
combat foreign interference let me fully
underline what colleagues have said for
time reasons just let me add one
additional point
in this case a non-governmental
organization was allegedly used or to be
more precise misused as Vector of
foreign interference in our political
work therefore we should also have a
look at existing regulations in order to
increase transparency and countability
of organizations and other actors thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Pedro Marcus
thank you very much president
commissioner
the accusations of corruption the data
that's already made available as some of
the worst things we've ever seen in this
institution as far as I'm concerned I
was outraged
from the very start and I get angry and
angrier for every new revelation that we
have to take note of I'm proud that my
group acted
has acted already in fact or
acted quickly and that this Parliament
acted quickly and that this member Eva
Cali was thrown out of our group and
stripped of her office of Vice President
of parliament but the confidence of
citizens in our institution has been
damaged
and within the framework of how we can
act we have to make sure that we
understand that we have been damaged as
well
the investigation committee needs to get
to the bottom of things it's important
to take measures to make sure that we
prevent ourselves from being attacked in
a similar way in the future it's
important to protect European democracy
as so many people have already said
that takes a long time to build up that
level of confidence and we've lost it in
the blink of an eye we have to change
this situation thank you
thank you very much
the next speaker is Adrian Vasquez
thank you very much president Madam
commissioner this week
the European Parliament has grabbed the
headlines of half the world but
unfortunately not because of the action
that we take to help citizens
it's about third countries that may have
bought
MEPS in a legitimate way this isn't just
a head I'm going to attack against the
parliament but also the values that
Inspire it but democracy and rule of law
are a lot stronger than some may think
to those who are corrupt to those who
corrupted to those who have allowed
themselves to be corrupted I'll say one
thing they're gonna catch you all and
you're going to pay for it
sooner or later because here the rule of
law works and a few rotten apples aren't
going to make the rest go rotten it is
our responsibility it's not going to be
straightforward to give back the
European Parliament uh the image and
reputation it deserves but we'll do so
whatever it takes
thank you very much
president
thank you very much the shadow of
corruption is hanging over us in
astonish the image of the European
Parliament but this threat isn't new we
already had suspicions that some
autocratic regimes might have been
trying to meddle in the work of this
Parliament through illicit means I said
this in 2017 through an abandonment
adopted by the parliament asking for
strong measures to avoid such corruption
that would undermine the legitimacy and
credibility of the work of the European
Parliament and that was a quote but we
didn't do anything and now the
suspicions have turned into criminal
charges I hope that we will act now and
take specific action such as setting up
an independent Ethics Committee with
real Powers with real teeth because we
also have to bear in mind that even with
stringent rules whether there's
corruption or not at all depends on our
sense of democratic responsibility and
ethics we cannot take any excuses when
it comes to corruption we've got to try
and ask ourselves questions and look at
ourselves in the mirror thank you it all
shows
thank you the next speaker is Anna von
Frisco you have the floor
thank you very much president
Qatar gate involves ngos trade unions
individuals MEP assistants and MEPS this
is the most serious political attack on
our democracy we're talking about
autocratic third countries that have
carried out these attacks and this is
the most serious attack since the
beginning of EU institutions
we are very critical when it comes to
Qatar and the enemies of democracy that
are a threat from the outside
and we put a parliamentary question it
was Mrs chicardi who put this question
and reflected these concerns however I
think we have to try and Stand United
this is extremely important to produce
the antibodies that we need to protect
our the society and freedom and
democracy are vital uh in order to
protect the presumption of innocence
we've got the rule of law and we all
believe in that we can speculate against
some members however we feel bitterness
because we've been excluded from the
Democratic process of the European
Parliament and being because we want to
be a constructive opposition
which is necessary
many of you
have used the Cordon sanitaire against
us but this was a tragic mistake yeah
given this disaster were let me repeat
what we said we're going to stand United
to defend European institutions and
European citizens
thank you very much next speaker Nicola
procaccini Presidente
thank you very much
it was said that corruption isn't
something that comes from the right or
the left I agree with this statement but
I wonder with our colleagues from the
left agree with this I fear that's not
the case because for years we've been
hearing them put forward the myth of
their moral super superiority and this
false and hypocritical narrative was
reflected in the speeches of some group
leaders the most disgusting aspect of
the Scandal is actually reflected in the
words that were uttered here one month
ago saying that Doha was a staunch
supporter of uh democracy and human
rights uh now now we understand these
comments a little bit more but that's
not why I'm mentioning it it's because
the left seems to think that it is in a
position to decide who is on the side of
history and who isn't and we've even
been told that the West could learn a
lot from Qatar when it comes to freedom
and riots this pervasive
opinion is the best ally of repression
and Corruption we have a question to ask
ourselves and not just in this chamber
why is an Islamic regime decide why have
they decided to pay off MEPS and invest
so much money in the most popular sport
in the world they're not looking for
economic profits or a rate of return
they are buying up our culture our way
of living everyone knows this but very
few are fighting against it
foreign
thank you very much
the next speaker is constantinos
armanitis you have the flop
I hope this is
ladies and gentlemen we can all feel the
stab in the back of our mutual trust or
their European Parliament democracy in
the rule of law but is of no value to
just focus on the findings even though
they are shocking I feel that we need to
adopt measures in order to make sure
that we restore the prestigious
substance of the institution when it
comes to criminal liability Justice will
decide but we have to assume our
political responsibility and that will
be reflected in the resolution tomorrow
we would like to see an independent
Ethics Committee set up with
investigation and enforcement powers
that will cover all institutions we want
to bolster the current rules on
transparency we want a transparency
register that will be legally binding
and mandatory we want a mandatory
legislative footprint for MEPS that
write reports and opinions we want a
revised code of conduct with more
stringent rules for MEPS and staff
especially when it comes to gifts and
services is we need to look at the whole
issue of a waving immunity when there
are members of a criminal organization
we've got Mr Lagos who's in prison but
he's still getting a salary and now we
have to put an end to the whole story
former MEPS their term has come to an
end and we thank them very much let us
put an end to this the comings and
goings here in the European Parliament
thank you
thank you very much
next we're going to hear from Gilbert
Kolar
foreign colleagues
the question is is there a fifth column
of corruption in the European Union yes
there is
and
what is to be done
ngos like fight impunity
uh
fighting impunity is indeed what we have
to do pan series former chair of the
subcommission on human rights the human
rights is a it's a scandal and I think
we need to get to get to the bottom of
this and thunder Lions SMS
the next speaker is Sven Simon
Mr President colleagues let me start by
congratulating the Belgian authorities
and our services on stopping this plot
to undermine European democracy
the silver lining in this case is that
our systems were tested and prevailed
but it is true
European democracy is under attack by
countries who seek to undermine our
decision-making processes
it is a shame
that a few colleagues
former colleagues and stuff went along
with this
the vector of attack in this case
appears to be an NGO
and for too long we have turned a blind
eye on the lobbying efforts of
supposedly non-governmental actors
what we need is a foreign agents
registration Act
modeled on the example in the United
States this means full transparency of
who is funding which NGO
their governance structures budgets and
persons of significant control
members who have taken money from ngos
have conflicts of interests it's not so
important which NGO or Lobby group and
they should recuse themselves
immediately from working in respective
policy fields
as European People's Party
we want to restore trust in the
functioning of our institutions
and we need to act now
not with political games but with
concrete actions
thank you
thank you Gabriela Bishop is next
ladies and gentlemen I think it's become
clear
that this week is a tough week for all
of us I've seldom seen so many feelings
coming to the surface so much anger so
much disappointment
and almost
also so many people have genuinely
shaken but this attack was just an
attack on our democracy which is an
attack on The credibility of our
Institution
is still something that demands that we
go beyond those feelings we've taken the
first step in great Unity
and I'd like to thank the commissioner
for the clear words that she spoke here
because we as an institution I think
will have to work closely together more
closely together to act against this
corruption against these criminals
that's why it is correct that for
example we should establish a an Ethics
body for all institutions I'm pleased
that the commissioner and the commission
president support this we need to bring
the council around to that we need to
make sure that we do our own homework in
terms of these jobs and we're going to
deal with this is as of the new year to
try and win back the faith that we've
lost thank you
thank you the next speaker is Hill
developments
thank you president commissioner
with the decision that we took today to
strip the vice presidentship from Ava
Kylie
we have sent out a very strong signal
today Europe is not for sale never
and it was a very important signal
because this corruption Scandal has
struck at the heart of our European
Parliament of our European project
when it comes to Catan I think everybody
here knows this we need to send this
back and we start with the visa-free
travel we need to make sure that we
carry out an appropriate investigation
the Belgian authorities have done
outstanding work but colleagues this is
only the start we have to have full
transparency of all Lobby contacts
within and out with the European
Parliament and look how the other
European institutions deal with this as
well because we need to push for a
broader approach we need to have
recommendations from the parliaments
committee on foreign interference and
Implement their recommendations we need
to look at how we can have a coordinated
Approach at European level and have a
genuine committed inquiry
these incidents happen but we need to
counter them on the basis of vision of
conviction not on the basis of money in
your bank account let this be a lesson
next is Hannah Neumann
we have all
been elected to represent European
citizens and entrusted to protect
European democracy and that is the very
Foundation of our mandate and it is so
across party lines
and colleagues until last Friday I was
pretty sure that the Descent that we
have the debates that are sometimes hard
but always at the core of democratic
decision making were based on political
opinions on different political opinions
and not on suitcases full of money
and this trust now is deeply shaken we
are all standing in the middle of a
crime scene with offices sealed
colleagues in prison confronted with the
allegation that at least one of us has
become a trojan horse of corruption and
foreign interference and I have no
Illusions autocratic regimes have tried
to bribe us before and they will
continue to do so in the future and that
is why I want this inquiry Committee of
the parliament to know more to know
better what has happened more to better
prevent it in the future and yes to
build trust again
our response to this Scandal dear
colleagues has to be clear to the inside
as well as the outside
we are not for sale and nor is European
democracy
is
thank you very much the next speaker is
Nicolas Fest
yes thank you Mr President
um
it's not just a problem of corrupt
members we've got corrupt ngos as well
one of them had founded fight impunity
the other Secretary General of no peace
without Justice both ngos had
practically the same address
this is a gateway to corruption this
kind of structure
Interpol is warning about the role of
ngos in money laundering the German
intelligence service is warning about
a systematic financing of left-wing ngos
by Qatar and other countries
corruption has been around for a long
time in this house because there is no
political scrutiny
in the senior bodies of this house
nothing's going to change because
they're in the hands of the left
thank you the next speaker iska
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
Miss Garcia Perez was talking about
safeguarding the honor of socialists and
Democrats
yet the s d has for years been trampling
on the honor of Poland in full disregard
of the facts
I wonder those
unwarranted attacks on Poland were they
paid for by somebody this Scandal
demonstrates the hypocrisy and double
standards in this house that cannot be
tolerated and it's not just in this
house it's also in the European
commission and the European commission
will have to tackle this problem
we therefore need a commission
with representatives of the member
states to monitor how the European
institutions are working
lobbying will have to be watched
particularly closely lobbying and
high-level corruption not just from
Qatar but also from Russia
for example
Nordstrom
climate policy there's an obvious need
for greater member State control over
the activities of the EU institutions
thank you very much
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Mark botenga
president
thank you very much president
commissioner one and a half million
million euros recovered
all sorts of offices searched
offices sealed even in this Parliament
obviously just the tip of the iceberg
every time we put forward an idea of
reducing the income of members you reply
no no you have to pay them well because
otherwise they'll be corrupted well
obviously
that's been going in a loop for years
now because it obviously isn't working
MEPS who are illegally corrupt by Qatar
is one thing that is bad enough
but MEP is being legally influenced
through revolving doors
seats on boards and such like is also
serious in Dutch this is a problem with
money culture there's almost no
transparency a culture of impunity in
Transparency International mentions this
and the high levels of salaries mean
that members have lost their grip on
reality they admire they'd rather live
with the bourgeoisie rather than as
normal people it's high time that
politicians
earn a decent wage and not take money
away from others
thank you very much next week is damash
Deutsch
is
the history of the European Union shows
the the gravest
corruption scandal
the Brussels corruption undermines the
whole credibility of every institution
it is obvious and clear that the left
wings and thy corruption narrative is a
cheap lie Kylie
foreign
narratives of these members of
parliaments are only to cover up for the
Brussels corruption
it was a thief who was calling for the
police as like in this story because you
based on political lies day by day
shame National governments for
corruption and want to penalize National
governments
meanwhile the Brussels corruption is
obviously rampant and it seems to be the
norm part of the system together with
politicians and ngos that are part of
this
plot Brussels has lost all of its
credibility with this candle you cannot
name and shame others for corruption
anymore
thank you very much
the next speaker is Ellen friedson
thank you president commissioner
I'm also both shocked and angry
that it seems like there is corruption
in this public elected Parliament that
doesn't just harm our European
Parliament as institution it also
damages politics it just it damages
politics in general but it damages
democracy
and I would like to express a vote of
thanks to Ola you want some for your
very clear words and yes they ought to
be ashamed
those who have committed the crimes
obviously should be brought to book
but at the same time we have to assume
our responsibility in the European
Parliament in the eu's institutions we
need to carry out reforms which strength
and transparency and openness and we
have to have a system in place where our
citizens have trust in what we're doing
they have to have faith in our
institutions they have to be able to
have confidence in us let us use our
anger that we now feel to make sure that
this never never happens again in our
Parliament thank you madam pretty talk
if you can perhaps stay because Mr
weimers has asked for a blue card to
intervene
you have the floor
president
[Music]
yes in November Helen fritson
the parliament majority wanted to have a
resolution that was critical of Qatar
you and your party camerade comrade Eric
bergson voted against that idea I'd just
like to know why I'd like to know why
the social Democrats in Sweden were in
favor of visa-free travel for Qatar
whereas the center party who are not
known for their such policies voted
against
foreign
this question from Charlie Raymond's my
answer to that will be that Charlie
Ramos knows very well that we voted on
formal points on the agenda when it came
to the resolution however I can tell you
very clearly that I as a Social Democrat
together with my group so stood behind
the rights of workers women and girls
rights and we do that each and every
occasion when we take important
decisions to contrary to Charlie Ramos
himself
[Applause]
thank you very much and Caroline check
is next
thank you chair they are colleagues
qatar's attempt to buy influence in the
European Parliament is absolutely
outrageous
but it also confronts us with a very
Grim reality
authoritarian countries are actively
trying to infiltrate European
institutions and let's face it our
safeguards are just not up for the task
right now we knew this was the case in
the European Council where Victor Orban
has been using his vetoes along the
interest of Russia or China undermining
Europe and now we see that foreign
influence has reached this Parliament as
well and it must have very far-reaching
consequences we need very urgent reform
in ethics and lobbying Frameworks and we
need a much better vetting system in
foreign policy personnel as well and our
message to Qatar must be crystal clear
attempts to silence us and to buy the
European Parliament will never succeed
we will never turn our back on human
rights violations on or on the thousands
of workers who have dialed while
constructing stadiums for their world
cup of shame in fact all Qatar achieved
with their bride money was that there we
will fight twice as hard to make sure
that there will be some consequences
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Eric marcat
thank you very much Mr President
corruption is toxic for democracy as
many people have said
the
European Parliament has is quite clearly
suffering from the poison
I've talked to a lot of people over the
past days
and it's good that most people are
saying that this is not just a few bad
apples and and certainly people are not
saying this is just a problem of one
political group the most important thing
the most important thing is that while
there may be a small number of guilty uh
people but the scale of the problem is a
big one and it's not just Qatar there
are other countries which are a threat
to democracy and we have to look at what
we can do better as an institution how
can we improve our transparency rules
and what can we do to make sure that our
transparency rules are actually
respected there are members who don't
who for three years haven't reported any
meetings with lobbyists that has to
change it's not just changing the rules
we've got rules
what can we do to enforce them what can
we do
to improve uh law enforcement what can
we do gradually to start rebuilding
trust thank you
thank you very much and the next speaker
is Jacques Madison
thank you very much
Mr President commissioner
colleagues the Belgium police has done
some good work
well done 600
000 Euro in plastic bags in European
Parliament Apartments that's uh that's
good work but it's probably just the tip
of the iceberg
seems that several s d members of
parliament have something to do with
Qatari corruption but there's probably
more to it than that corruption is
a serious problem we have to combat but
there's a whiff of corruption in what
the commission president has been doing
the parliament
has
the the parliament has
expressed its concern about the deletion
of uh text messages and WhatsApp
messages from the commission President's
phone
exchanges about three and a half billion
worth of taxpayers money with uh Pfizer
unfortunately the European commission is
brushing this under the carpet if we
really want to fight corruption we have
to stop their secrecy as the Ombudsman
O'Reilly has said
if you are secretive then there will be
suspicion
uh
it's high time that something be done
about this thank you
thank you very much and we chances
of course there is the whole aspect of
justice and it's the hand of the judges
but this is also a political uh case
that we cannot ignore
the lobbies have huge power and huge
influence here in the European
Parliament whether it's multinationals
foreign countries or ngos Qatar gate
shows that the NGO issue is something
that we have to pay particular attention
to look at most of the proposals that
come to the Committees to see how much
pressure is put on us to make sure that
these pseudo-humanitarian organizations
bring their influence to bear on the
decision making there were very
ambiguous cases such as the conflict of
interest between the ngos and European
Court of human rights now
they have an impact on the daily life of
democracy without enough information and
which interests they support I think
that the committee of inquiry on Qatar
gate is necessary but not enough if we
want the European institutions to get
their transparency and credibility back
then we have to make sure that OPAC
lobbies don't have a hold on the
parliament anymore and make sure that
only those who have the P Mandate of the
people can do the work they do
thank you very much and the next speaker
is Costas
the womb that engenders corruption is
the European Union itself the EU of big
capital and of course we have the Kaili
case which also involves other present
and former MEPS your resolution
whitewashing Qatar was adopted without a
roll call vote the EU the Epp and the
social Democrats uh seem to talk about
uh exemplary labor reforms and this on
the graves of those who died and of
course this was backed by the ituc head
who is now being prosecuted
now you talk about Qatar being strategic
partners and you talked about Visa
waivers but now all of a sudden they've
become an authoritarian regime that
attacks European democracy so you've now
discovered this while standing next to
this mire and we've got this suspicious
ngos but now even though you've
discarded that now you're giving us new
myths and stories about ethics codes
good lobbies transparency the peoples
have to draw their own conclusions the
EU and the rotten capitalist system
cannot be reformed only overthrown by
The People's struggles thank you
thank you very much the next speakers
thank you very much president
the investigation is bringing deplorable
facts to the light and the European
Parliament needs to Stand United and
decide on what has to be done I'm
furious and upset about the fact that
former MEPS current MEPS and assistants
that have been colleagues of ours for
many years have been involved in this
but of course Justice will take its
course and I would like to say that any
attempt to bring influence to bear on my
parliamentary group will fail our
delegation even within our political
group decided to vote
in favor of the left amendments uh
boosting the whole issue of workers
rights which is the right throughout
that we also put two questions over the
last few months about the World Cup to
vice president Borel will take all the
necessary initiatives in order to make
sure the truth comes to the fore and
that we talk about our work and the
battles we carry out we need a new
anti-corruption law with the
commissioner at the helm we need to have
an independent European Body responsible
for ethics we've discussed this with
other political groups and uh that have
been against but I hope they will change
their minds we really have to
um do this properly to make sure that
there is not the interest of a few that
Prevail thank you
thank you the next speaker is Valerie
thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
there's been foreign interference in
Parliament there have been Russian
attacks on Cyber Terror in the line of
cyber terrorism and now we see that
Qatar has managed to influence our
members through votes and policies
there's no more no less than corruption
it seems that some people here ignore
the moral imperative of their mandate
so yes we need transparency
but as bad as these acts of interference
are
the acts of individuals are putting at
risk of faith in our institutions
corruption has no place in our
institutions and this is why
I would not hesitate hesitate to waive
immunity if necessary
facing corruption our group renew will
be intransigent it will also be in
transition in the reforms that need to
be carried out so that this is never
seen again
we need to have more transparency since
99 we've been pushing for this
commissioner this was a promise from
Ursula thunderline and we are now ready
thank you Madame Aubry has requested a
blue card
so please the floor is yours
under the new rules uh yeah she doesn't
need to uh okay the the blue card so you
have the floor at the mobility
it could be a statement
well thank you very much president I
thought I'd be able to put the question
to Valerie Ayer who's refusing to field
it I'm going to put it nevertheless
it'll remain with a question mark at the
end of it to maybe she'll be able to
resolve my concerns I do share uh
indignation against this biggest Scandal
of corruption uh it's unprecedented I
have a couple of questions first of all
how do you explain that Emmanuel macron
said in this context just a few weeks
ago that this world cup bear Sesame to
changes afoot and the qatars are going
along the right path and they can count
on our support that was his uh his tweet
in fact a word for word secondly given
this context how can a Manuel macaw
except to go to Qatar not boycott it and
support this in this way a government
which is in in the process of corrupting
our Parliament I'm afraid I'm not going
to get an answer to those
thank you very much and next we're going
to hear from Eddie heldala
so colleagues um some have already
pointed out that stricter ethics rules
would not have prevented the kind of
serious criminal acts that we have now
seen
but I want to convince you that Lex
rules on the other hand can create
opportunities for corruption an
organizational culture that turns a
blind eye to smaller indiscretions of
members only serves to enable more
serious abuses of office the parliament
has been until now light handed in
dealing with dodgy friendship groups
false electoral observation missions and
questionable use of members allowances
the free Mandate of an MEP is not an
excuse to act against the core values of
our Union
the proposed Committee of inquiry must
have a strong mandate for far-reaching
reforms to protect this house from undue
foreign influence and other abuses of
power importantly new rules on members
conduct must include enforcement and
sanctions until now they are just
symbolic and back in 2021 may I remind
you I wrote a letter to President sasoli
together with colleague luxman and Made
Concrete proposals on undue foreign
influence we received no reply
the threat of foreign influence must now
finally be taken seriously
[Applause]
from Madame Mercure please the floor is
yours
shout out you mentioned that you wrote a
letter in 2021 to the president of the
parliament with concrete proposals could
you elaborate on what the concrete
proposals were in that letter thank you
very much
thank you for your question colleague
melchior first of all the simple thing
that we could have done on that day we
could still do today is that we oblige
foreign embassies and diplomats and
other foreign actors to to be registered
in the transparency register and then of
course this question of of wild
um Unum Authority authorized election
observation should be tackled because we
have in our rules
the protection of of the Dignity of the
parliament so members should not be
allowed in activities that damage the
reputation of the parliament and we
should give a broad interpretation to
this including electoral observations
missions that only are in favor of
strengthening autocrats that we don't
want as an institution to defend
thank you very much
the next speaker is Carlos Butch Demond
you have to flow sure there is a
political culture in Europe and in
certain countries of the Union which
consist of increasing leniency towards
human rights violations a straight
exchange increase
Qatar friendly Europe is an example of
this political culture as are the
lucrative relation between Spain and the
regime of Saudi Arabia Arabia
we
one only needs to see the sympathy and
praise of commissioner skinners every
time he has met with Qatari
representatives to understand what the
official narrative is
when economic interest watered down the
demand for respect for human rights the
door to corruption opens a little more
maybe we should try to be less friendly
and more demanding thank you
[Applause]
thank you
and the next speaker is Nicos Andrew
luckis
first of all congratulations to the
Belgian authorities that revealed this
scandal
unlike others that are trying to cover
up scandals no one has the right
to put the parliament in this position
it we have to protect transparency and
democracy we shouldn't become an example
to avoid that is why when I heard about
this shocking case as soon as I heard
this I immediately through Mrs Kylie out
of the party we cannot same say that
we're all the same we have to prove this
with our actions so the time for action
has come and that is why I suggest
number one to not allow European
officials during their term of office to
become a lobbyist
oh we have a special service that helped
MEPS check whether there was spyware on
their phones I suggest they're already
tomorrow morning we have a special body
that will check all the assets of MEPS
and how they got those assets we need to
go through all of this with a fine tooth
comb these two actions will help shed
light on the situation and will make
sure that there isn't a trace of Shadow
hanging over this house we
owe it to the citizens we represent and
the European dream thank you
thank you very much Karen melchior has
the floor thank you very much president
thank you commissioner
the extent of the alleged corruption is
Criminal it must be prosecuted and we
must investigate how we can do better
however no matter how good the rules are
there will always be criminals who take
the risk and the suitcase of Euro notes
but we can make stronger rules we need
to clean up our act in the European
Parliament we need to do away with
informal friendship groups outside the
rules of the parliament replace them
with regulated inter-political groups we
need to extend our transparency register
to representatives of foreign
governments and former MEPS
thank you colleagues and commissioner
for your support for an Ethics body with
investigative powers for all EU
institutions which renew Europe has
called for since 2019 and rules cannot
stand alone we must not accept
colleagues being unduly influenced to
change wordings votes and legislation
to help expose criminality we must make
our whistleblower system stronger and
finally to my colleagues if you see
something that seems odd or out of line
with previous opinions or known facts
then do something confront your
colleagues and even your political
leadership it is a joint responsibility
to prevent the corruption of the few
thank you
thank you very much
my first words are to thank and support
Belgian Justice and the Belgian police
for uncovering this very serious case of
Corruption of course the the main
responsible parties are those who allow
themselves to be corrupted and those who
did the corrupting but we cannot think
that this is just an isolated case that
doesn't affect the institution it has
affected the image of the European
Parliament especially at a difficult
time where people are finding it very
hard and this means that people feel
even more disaffected and increase the
disillusion in the institutions now but
let us be
let us be careful
let us make sure we deal with this
properly we it would be a mistake to
just replace Mrs Kaylee as vice
president that would be superficial we
need a route and Branch reform of our
transparency rules the Parliament can
not still be the weak Link in the system
we need very deep reform of how we carry
out our work
thank you
and the next book is Dino Russo
president
ladies and gentlemen what a disgrace
it's a terrible disgrace in this house
how many billions does this House cost
us how much does it cost each and every
citizen how many billions to be caused
people were talking about the dreams and
hopes of a better life European citizens
placed their trust for these in us we
have betrayed them and The Pact of trust
has been
tarnished we're talking about bags of
banknotes in the homes of colleagues
former colleagues trade unions it just
reminds you of the money that the mafia
has heaps of money it's a disgrace today
is a terrible day and president metzola
and everyone below her please take
action not just words but action we need
to fight against corruption we need
stringent rules we need to punish those
who are guilty today but make sure that
we create the right conditions so that
in the future no one can steal the
future of Europeans their trust and
their money let us throw out everyone
who is corrupt and is corrupting from
this house and make sure that there is
no possibility in the future of doing
this otherwise there will be no reason
data for the European Parliament
ladies and
gentlemen
we are
completely shamed by this and we mustn't
be in transition we have to act
we've seen that there are old things
have come back to haunt us here
is to
Ben Hadley gave us a direction to follow
to fight impunity we have to really move
in that direction we have to have a
committed inquiry we have to have a high
Authority that is responsible for
transparency in public life we need to
make sure that Elites in Europe are not
captured by Foreign actors what we need
to find today or refined is courage the
courage to counter these foreign
countries be they China Russia or Qatar
who do their shopping in our democracy
we
as members and chair of this our
investigative committee a special
committee have been pushing this point
Europe is not for sale
thank you very much and the next speaker
is
thank you very much president
Mrs Kaylee has been stripped of her vice
presidency but she was held by strong
interest in Greece in her political
career interests that have a hold on the
media and he was also helped by lobbies
in the European institutions
her career and her full are an example
that we need to get inspiration from
when it comes to new rules we have to
make sure that we curb these interests
now the foreign influence including
qatars who thinks that he can buy
anything has to be curtailed drastically
we need to be self-critical the Italian
socialists gave her so many
opportunities
and evaluators who always thought her
scientific proposals and applications
for funding were excellent and all those
who promoted the products of digital
Giants with Mrs Kylie at a Helm please
don't kid yourselves it's not only Qatar
ladies and gentlemen
stupid
thank you the next speaker is munir
Satori
chocolate
colleagues the corruption scandal
which is shaking this institution is of
the worst kind this corruption sought to
silence this house on human rights many
authoritarian regimes meddle in Europe's
democracy they seek to achieve their
objectives to buy an image this time it
was a Qatar
with its World Cup built are on
exploited workers
for years we have been asking for
measures to be taken we are calling for
a European ethics Authority and a
committee of inquiry up to the task
we need
to have the dissuasive measures in place
they will always be corruption that is
why you need anti-corruption measures
but I say to the corrupters the way to
create an image of yourselves is to
respect people's rights and not by
buying the votes of members
thank you very much Francesco Donato is
the next speaker
thank you president Madam commissioner
ladies and gentlemen the serious
corruption charges that have emerged
surrounding MEPS assistants have caused
shock
Among Us uh I think that the rules
pertaining to lobbying and transparency
are not enough to prevent corruption but
that's not just here in the European
Parliament but that also applies to the
European commission the president of the
European commission is also being looked
into
given the whole issue of public
procurement of vaccines but I haven't
heard anyone
utter any words of indignation no one
has asked her to stand down Giants such
as Pfizer or digital lobbies or defense
lobbies do you think that they have less
influence and power than Qatar and that
they can't really influence our
decisions to their benefit we need to
have a committee of inquiry we owe this
to our citizens and they need to look at
what I've just talked about and not just
Qatar uh
thank you very much the next speaker is
Agnes John Harris
thank you very much president well
indeed it does seem a bit like a
surrealist Netflix film
but when you wake up you realize that
it's actually reality cold hard reality
ladies and gentlemen in our Parliament
and in ngos there's been corruption in
our worst dreams I don't think we ever
would have thought up such a scenario
trust in European democracy has been
um undermined and I think the only thing
we can do here is condemn this in
knowing certain terms there's no place
for corruption not now not ever
but at the same time it is not
the time to just
come out with fine words we have to come
out with acts and deeds and those deeds
have to start at home which means
alongside setting up our own
committative inquiry I would urge that
we establish an independent
investigation into these incidents
and at the same time I would say we need
to support the call for a revision of
the rules
to look first of all at the third com
third countries that have untrammeled
access to the European Parliament it's
time for actions time for Deeds thank
you
thank you very much Daniel freund is
next
colleagues
corruption is the greatest threat to our
democracy
corruption is Criminal and people with
cycloads of cash belong in prison
but for the European Parliament this
issue will not be over when the Belgian
authorities have finished their work
there are some people in this house who
don't seem to understand what a member
can and cannot do
how is it possible that members of this
house let ruthless dictators pay for
their trips how is it that some members
don't publish their meetings with
lobbyists how is it that members face no
penalties despite repeatedly breaching
the rules of the house colleagues I've
really had enough there are a few uh bad
apples here who are dragging the image
of this house into the Maya
meetings should be declared including
meetings with qataris and the lobbying
rules have to be enforced otherwise with
the next Scandal is just going to be
around the corner this is the time to
act now we can do something
[Applause]
thank you very much now we have the
catch the eye procedure
and we have Maria Walsh as the first
speaker
I know it's shocking to read news of
police investigations into the work of
an elected official and staff of the
parliament it is shocking to me and
Incredibly shocking to our EU citizens
and it is important that due process is
followed today in Stroudsburg I along
with 624 MEPS voted for an early
termination of the office of Vice
President of the parliament Eva Kylie
the public should be able and needs to
be able to to trust the work of us MEPS
and the Parliament staff at the end of
the day we are elected to by the public
for the public to carry out our work in
public interest and are answerable to
the people that is our job
Corruption of any Nature has no place in
our political landscape here or uh in
Our member State I welcome any internal
investigations and improved procedures
to uphold the reputation of our EU
institutions we need to be transparent
to be accountable and to do what is
right I stand for a strong Europe a fair
Europe and a trusted Europe thank you
very much
[Applause]
thing
thank you the next speaker is Juan
Fernando Lopez Aguilar
thank you very much commissioner
Johansson
the European Parliament was the first
parliament in the world
to
[Music]
protect whistleblowers
and the European Parliament has really
come down hard against corruption and
money laundering and that is why the
European Parliament has to Stand United
there mustn't be any cracks when it
comes to condemning those who have
corrupted and those who have been
corrupted of course the the judicial
procedure is
happening but we also have to make sure
that we protect our integrity and
transparency the most accessible and
transparent parliament of the world but
we also have to Rally behind the
condemnation of anyone
who shows because they're being
prosecuted that they never deserved the
trust that were put in them
because it is a duty and something of
dignity to represent the European people
in this house thank you
thank you very much
is the next speaker
events Integrity transparency Integrity
anti-corruption fairness and human
rights for months now we've been
speaking about these topics especially
in conjunction with Qatar FIFA and
football first of all now our democracy
in Europe
but the demands have remained the same
we have to work for our values together
we as an institution have to work
against the under influence of others we
need to look a little closer and be
accountable Millions for sports washing
green washing with FIFA now 25 million
for social washing with the ILO
it's just a question of time before we
start finding more receipts Qatar has
money
they want to buy themselves a better
image but the EU is not for sale and
there will be consequences for all of
those
who are happy to have a price tag
thank you very much the next speaker
thank you very much presidents ladies
and gentlemen as with all of you I'm
deeply shocked by the
incident that we're seeing here I'm very
pleased that the police have acted very
powerfully and an independent Judiciary
in action we have to I think review uh
rules on transparency and openness but I
would warn against having an
inter-institutional Ethics body
comprised of third parties who are meant
to be independent to check whether we're
implementing our own rules
we should not be uh we should not allow
ourselves to be controlled and monitored
scrutinized by another body out with the
European Parliament we are here as a
monitoring scrutinizing body not the
other way around we have to work through
this by strengthening and bolstering our
own code of conduct
thank you very much
is the next speaker
more than one and a half million euro in
cash
uh that's 94 years on your minimum wage
so a couple working for years wouldn't
make the amount of money that Qatar used
to corrupt uh Europeans so most of us
weren't given suitcases full of Banker
notes
but we know what fishing is all about
fishing is a technique used giving us
baits as if we were fish I got this in
my Parliament mailbox yesterday I was
invited to go to one of the most
luxurious hotels in Brussels by the
Qatar Embassy two weeks before I was
invited to go to Qatar itself and to
visit the stadia and to meet the trade
unions and to
see how Qatar had adopted a set of
measures in order to reinforce social
protection and labor conditions so we
really need to deal with the root causes
of this so that unbridled lobbing and
Corruption are no longer like efficient
water in the European Parliament
[Applause]
thank you very much
is the next speaker
there are no sacred cows in the European
Parliament the vice president arrested
what does the Union do
first
cooperate with the authorities second
a stripper of her
rights third
remove her as vice president fourth a
debate in plenary and a resolution the
EU has reacted
there is no easy ride for those who have
betrayed Europe's values because that's
what it's about in rule of law you have
to react if people break the law you
have to act because everyone is equal
there are things that uh
the things that people have
forgotten about what happened in Poland
in the past I think you need to learn
from what Europe is doing zero tolerance
to corruption Zero Tolerance of breaking
the law
thank you very much
Anna Miranda
is not a scandal you cannot do business
with politics so what do some MEPS think
they are do they think they're Gods we
represent our peoples we don't peddle
votes and influence ethics
responsibility work integrity and
transparency are extremely important and
should be part and parcel of our mandate
our political group have often denounced
corruption we've often said that we are
being contacted by lobbies and the big
groups didn't do anything there's
foreign influence by countries such as
Israel turkey Morocco and Qatar this is
nothing new ladies and gentlemen we
demand a committee of inquiry and we
demand Zero Tolerance against corruption
to be honest I'm extremely surprised
that the Spanish PP isn't represented
here in the chamber I'm very surprised
m.rahoy
foreign
thank you
petrosco Carlos is the next speaker
thank you president as we see
photographs of piles of gas found in the
hands of members of our European
Parliament Community how can citizens
not wonder how much money is there that
we don't see
it is really existential to for the
Integrity of our house to immediately
and radically reform our governance
structure and provide the transparency
and accountability that the citizens
will represent demand and deserve and we
must start this week tomorrow I think
with a resolution that will demonstrate
credibly our commitment to take concrete
measures many proposed by previous
speakers to bring our house in order and
give us the opportunity to rebuild the
trust that is necessary to perform a
real duty to exercise parliamentary
scrutiny over the commission and the
council and to resist not only foreign
interference but also domestic
interference thank you very much
foreign
thank you very much
Deanna everybody here is the next
speaker
thank you very much president
commissioner
the Qatar gate information is serious
especially
since it rocks the foundations of any
democracy and that is the people's trust
there's something we must never forget
we are all here in this chamber for the
same unique reason it's because the
citizens have placed their trust in us
the images of the police taking
suitcases away with hundreds of
thousands of Euro from MEPS and others
working for the institution is not only
a disgrace for us but it also is
disgusts us deeply we have to be
implacable let us set up a committee of
inquiry let us set up an independent
ethics body that can investigate all EU
institutions let us put an end to
donations from third countries for
political foundations and MEPS let us
make sure that we have a transition
period for former MEPS whose term comes
to an end so that they don't peddle
their influence for the same reasons
we've seen here zero tolerance for
corruption and zero tolerance of those
have been corrupted
thank you very much and that brings to a
conclusion the catch the eye procedure
and now we're going to hear from
commissioner Johansson to conclude on
behalf of the European Commission
thank you president thank you members of
this Parliament
thank you for this very important debate
and thank you for channeling your anger
and frustration into firm commitment to
do what's necessary to rebuild Trust
there must be zero tolerance for
corruption
it's a very serious crime that
undermines our democracy economy and
society and as a union we need to learn
the hard lessons and take responsibility
this scandal
we discussed here today goes well beyond
ethics violations
it's a criminal investigation
even though we urgently need the EU
ethics body for All European
institutions this is a criminal
investigation and the only way we can
rebuild trust is to fully support this
investigations for the guilty to be
brought to Justice
and for us to root out corruption
anywhere we find it
and finally
let me say that our debate today also
gives me hope
the strong word spoken on condemnation
the demand for justice and action
we are at the beginning of a struggle
that we belong and hard
bringing the guilty to Justice will be
comparatively the easy part
rebuilding Trust
that will be hard
let's be honest about this
to do that our fight against corruption
must be unrelenting
uncompromising
unforgiving
in our Union in Our member states and in
our institutions
to show everyone it's not this Scandal
that defines us but our resolve
determination and action to do
everything it takes to do what is right
thank you
[Applause]
foreign thank you very much and that
concludes the debate the vote will take
place on Thursday
the next item on the order paper is
Council and commission statements
the recent jha Council decision on
Schengen accession and first we're going
to hear from Minister Vladimir balash on
behalf of council
president
the Mr President The Madam commissioner